toute la journée je chantais donc je
crois depuis que je suis toute petite
toute petite fille je crois qu'il me
serait jamais venu à l'idée de faire
autre chose que de
[Musique]
chanter la divine facilité où le chant
très haut Mad Robin la cantatrice
tourangel en était la digne
représentante un jour Mad Robin
complètement par hasard j'ai lu la voix
la plus haute du monde ça m'a intrigué
donc j'ai écouté ind dis de M de Robin
et là j'ai la révélation parce que là on
a affaire à une voix complètement unique
il y a pas eu de morbin elle est la
seule à avoir atteint des notes sur
aigu si aigu qu'aucun compositeur
n'avait pensé un jour les écrire je suis
tourangel je suis née à isur sur Creuse
un tout petit pays charmant du reste qui
se trouve en douren près de La Roche
posée et son village natal là où elle
repose depuis son décès prématuré en
1960 ne l'a pas oublié même si ce fut
long pendant plus de 40 ans
d'innombrables souvenirs sont restés
dans les cartons c'est sa nièce sa plus
fervante admiratrice qui l'a suivi au
fil des représentation qui a fini par
convaincre la mairie de donner vie à la
mémoire quand je me suis mariée elle
avait déplacé tout le les cœurs de
l'Opéra et même Lili Laskine à ma messe
de mariage qui a été enregistrée
d'ailleurs ça je pense que c'est un
grand souvenirin mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres tout aussi grandios tout aussi
touchant tout aussi émouvant c'était
pour nous très très important c'était
une volonté ancienne et madobin donc a
marqué son époque et elle est née à
easer elle repose à eer et eer se devait
de de de de célébrer son souvenir et je
pense qu'on a pas trop mal réussi le
musée permet aux visiteurs de se plonger
dans les vies de Mado Robin privé et
artistiqu photos costumes objets
affiches partition et surtout des
extraits de sa voix semblant venir du
ciel la voix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'un